[Música]
salud en directo América de France 24 me
acompaña como todas las mañanas en el
estudio mar Romero sala mar vamos a
hablar de lo que podemos considerar una
buena noticia no hablamos del Alzheimer
el medicamento que ha ocupado los
titulares toda esta semana por su
posible efectividad Sí así es Raúl
hablamos del decanemap y yo traigo
buenas y malas noticias yo no sé si pero
digamos
a veces somos un poco aguafiestas pero
todo es para dar una información
no es la primera vez que hablamos de
este medicamento de hecho en a finales
de septiembre ya se publicaron los
resultados preliminares de este estudio
ahora se han publicado ya en una revista
revisada por ropares no hablamos del New
england Medical journal Entonces digamos
que tienen más peso estos resultados son
las mismas cifras Sin embargo a pesar de
que ahora vengan avaladas por todo este
proceso de revisión se administró este
lecanemap a dos grupos de pacientes no
por un lado los pacientes en su Grupo
Control El que te recibían un placebo y
por los pacientes que recibían pues el
medicamento real en total eran casi 1800
personas participantes todos en etapas
leves todavía del Alzheimer de la
enfermedad Mientras que el declive
cognitivo en las personas que recibieron
placebo después de un año y medio fue de
1,66 puntos en los pacientes que
recibieron el medicamento fue en cambio
de 1,21 puntos esto en una escala de 18
puntos que se usa para medir digamos el
deterioro relacionado con la demencia
que se le llama cdr No entonces vemos
que en realidad ahí empieza un poco El
dilema de las cifras la diferencia en la
de las cifras de estos puntos en la
escala de 18 es de 0,45 Aunque en verdad
también es cierto que si se comparan los
resultados es una ralentización del
deterioro de un 27% entonces bueno Ahí
es donde empezamos a ver esa diferencias
de opiniones sobre todo que ahora mismo
dividen a la comunidad científica y
vamos a hablar de esos resultados las
implicaciones que pueden tener mar como
decíamos pues difieren no para algunos y
sobre después de décadas de
investigaciones infructuosas en el
alzheimer esto es un resultado que se
acerca algo revolucionario escuchemos
lo que representa para mí es que por
primera vez podríamos tener un
tratamiento que ralentice el alzheimer
Y eso es algo verdaderamente
revolucionario porque hasta ahora
tenemos algunos tratamientos que han
tenido beneficios leves pero que
realmente no tenían efectos sobre los
componentes clave de la enfermedad y no
la reducía sustancialmente
por ejemplo dicen no que esta diferencia
de 0,45 puntos para algunos así sea
pequeña en estos momentos de inicio de
la enfermedad puede ser un cambio muy
significativo para la calidad de vida de
los pacientes pero también de las
personas de los familiares de los
allegados que los cuidan mientras que
hay otros que dicen que este margen en
realidad tiene que ver si realmente va a
tener unas implicaciones una diferencia
significativa en la cotidianidad de
estas personas y que quizás esta pequeño
margen de diferencia no merece digamos
todo este bombo y platillo que se le
está dando a la noticia que al final
también pues recordemos que afecta mucho
a los sentimientos de los millones de
personas que sufren esta enfermedad y de
sus seres queridos una enfermedad
realmente dura mar pero este medicamento
También recibe el escepticismo Por sus
efectos secundarios de qué podemos
hablar sí tenemos que ponerlos también
sobre la mesa y es que hay diferencias
estadísticas en algunos efectos
secundarios tanto entre el grupo Control
el grupo que recibe el placebo como el
grupo que recibió el medicamento por
ejemplo en el caso de la inflamación del
cerebro en el grupo de los pacientes que
sí recibieron el medicamento quería
decir tuvieron un 10,8 puntos
porcentuales a más de casos de
inflamación de cerebro que los que no lo
recibieron o no también sucedió lo mismo
con la microemorragia de una diferencia
significativa de 8,3 puntos entre los
que no reciben el medicamento y los que
sí en general el 17% de los pacientes
que recibieron el medicamento tuvieron
estas microemorragias en general Es
verdad que se dice que muchas pues
efectos secundarios no tienen por qué
traducirse en sintomatología y que con
un monitoreo constante se pueden evitar
las consecuencias graves un monitoreo
constante Por cierto que también
aumentaría entonces el precio que supone
dar este medicamento sin embargo también
Es verdad que hay dos personas que
estaban en este estudio clínico que
fallecieron aunque se está estudiando
Realmente si tuvo que ver pues con la
administración de medicamento estaba
relacionado Pues con las múltiples
condiciones de salud que También tenían
que ver y que sabemos hablabas de precio
evidentemente la farmacéuticas que están
detrás de este medicamento claro no no
debemos olvidarlas es japonesa que se
alió con la estadounidense bioy que
compraron la idea y las primeras formas
del lecanemap en 2007 de una pequeña
empresa sueca llamada bioartica y vemos
también por ejemplo como sus acciones el
precio de sus acciones aumentó muy
significativamente a partir de la
publicación a finales de septiembre de
los resultados en nota de prensa no en
estudios científicos de
medicamento no como aumenta
significativamente el precio de sus
acciones su valor en bolsa y es que hay
dinámicas muy estrechas también Al final
entre las expectativas de la gente los
medios de comunicación y la rentabilidad
el dinero que buscan también pues
recaudar las farmacéuticas también pues
como retribución de sus investigaciones
y de sus inversiones sin embargo pues es
importante que no nos dejemos nublar un
poco a veces por esas notas de prensa
por eso es tan importante que esta
semana se publicarán estos resultados en
estudios científicos no hay además algo
que está en juego y es que por supuesto
esto se puede considerar si se
consideran positivos o negativos los
resultados de esta investigación un
espaldarazo definitivo a una teoría no
la teoría de los betamiloides que es de
esa proteína que se acumula en el
cerebro de los pacientes con Alzheimer y
que durante muchos años las principales
líneas de investigación en las
farmacéuticas Ha sido contrarrestar este
efecto de estas proteínas y que así se
van a revertir O al menos pues frenar el
deterioro cognitivo del Alzheimer
entonces para los que están a favor
digamos de este tratamiento es la prueba
definitiva de que esto ha resultado bien
y esta también es lo que van a defender
pues obviamente las farmacéuticas que
han invertido millones y millones en
este tipo de investigaciones mientras
que hay otros que siguen pues
dependiendo que todavía no hay tanto
consenso que no estamos tan claros Y eso
también podría suponer Pues por supuesto
una derrumbe económico para muchas
empresas que han financiado todo esto
entonces Bueno también a mí me parece
importante destacar que la historia de
la investigación contra el alzheimer al
final también depende de unos intereses
económicos que están ahí detrás Así es
más el dinero Muchísimas gracias como
siempre por toda la información en
materia de salud mar buen fin de semana
y por supuesto el lunes con más noticias
de salud el lunes nos vemos Raúl